two last questions one really simple one
absurdly ridiculous and perhaps also
simple
first who is ben and is he real
i don't even know what you're talking
about very well
how's that for an answer it's like
asking me is harvey the white rabbit
reel i don't know
there's carrots all around the
production room but i don't know what
that means
well a lot of people demanded that i
prove
i somehow figure out a way to prove the
existence if i said he was real
people would say no he's not and if i
said he was if he wasn't real they would
say yes he is so
it's a santa claus easter bunny kind of
vibe there
yeah i mean what is real anyway that's
exactly what i told him
you